trainer gets caught on camera being a
pervert and when i stand up for myself
he threatens to call the police and
revoke my membership
[Music]
do you need something
do you need something
do you do something
okay
[Music]
okay i understand that women have to put
up with a lot in situations like these
but the video doesn't show anything more
than a glance and then we get right into
do you need something to then blasting
their face on the internet and calling
them a pervert it's also worth pointing
out that she slowed the footage down so
this look is actually in slow motion
making it seem longer and she added the
caption oh damn when clearly his mouth
is moving way too much to have said oh
damn dude was in mid-sentence when he
turned around
this bait
what you mean this bait
um
okay first thing first
yes mr trainer you were looking some
type of way you were
you were you looked at her you was like
well damn
fine you're like oh you you you looked
at her because you saw something and
it's fine
miss
if you remove your shirt
people are going to look
it's a gym it's predominantly uh well
man some men are going to look but you
take your shirt off
people are gonna look if i take my shirt
off [ __ ] are gonna look they
didn't say anything and talk to you
people will look you remove your whole
shirt
there's lockers [ __ ] going look
i don't know in what universe you live
in where anybody
small big thick
fit
whatever remove they shirt
and people not looking people are gonna
look every time someone's gonna make a
movement of removing something people
are gonna look
for different type of reasons so yeah
that's bait
you overreacted
you really overreacted on that one
and the reason why you're trying to
remove your
membership
was because you're being a threat to him
because he don't know what kind of
things you're going to accuse him of and
guess what you just did and it was
really nothing to accuse him of you move
your whole shirt
why is you filming
it's fine you're allowed to film still
such as [ __ ]
nah it's okay apparently she got kicked
out afterwards i like dancing i like
skating i like doing a lot of physical
activity in the process of doing that
when i'm playing music
using wired earphones doesn't cut it for
me for the last two three months i only
use these recons that's it
when i travel i play them on the plane
they last what i think it's like eight
hours of play time 32 hours of battery
life the gels on these earbuds do not
budge they stay in there if you're
anything like me you like using these
earbuds when you're dancing or working
out perfect because not only are they
sweat resistant but they're also water
resistant and best of all
affordability not only do raycon earbuds
sound just as good as other leading
wireless earbuds but they offer the same
premium quality if not better at half
the price and so for me just judging by
the build quality the great price point
this is a steal i love the product i
think it's great and i want you guys to
be able to gain access to it so if you
want your own raycons go to the link in
the description below or go to biorecon
dot com slash abba for 15 off your recon
purchases i mean
that's fine
listen ladies i know you get approached
a lot and um i've even seen videos where
dudes like literally stalk you around
the gym follow you around there's one
video that was really weird where dude
was like staring for a good life
so i understand
but it isn't because you deal with that
that you get to be primed and charged at
anybody it's like you're taking off
clothes yeah someone's gonna turn around
i'm gonna turn around what's happening
it could be a girl could be a dude if
somebody's always said start taking all
their clothes i'm gonna just turn
who's a stoic [ __ ] person who sees
like things just changing all around
them are just like
nobody does that okay if you're being
honest in the gym everybody glances here
and there this is very rare you see
anybody explain
the whole time
you're glanced you're glad you're gonna
see what happened okay now somebody's
going
damn
okay
you're feeling you know if they're doing
all that okay i understand if you saw
that they glanced you glanced
how did you know they was looking at you
if you wasn't looking at it
you removed your [ __ ] and you glanced
cause we glanced
also also let's keep it a stack man you
know what i mean y'all out there wearing
the tightest [ __ ] you know i mean
basically putting out the most amount of
[ __ ] bait has pre-set you're doing
somebody glances and you lose your mind
really you're doing too much come on
you're doing too much come on you're
doing too much and that is really not to
discredit every time that a girl goes to
the gym and there's a creeper or every
time you go to the street and there's a
creeper that's not that that's good at
that but that was not that this is what
this is you know what this is it's like
they do kind of like hey how are you the
[ __ ] men always bothering it's like
some dude just came up and just said hey
how are you
i get it so there's some creepy dudes
out there not every approach is a creepy
approach
not everybody who says hi to you wants
everything from you
forget what i'm trying to say i
understand this people do that okay cool
not everything is that though but yes
and then afterwards [ __ ] gonna
get mad when nobody glances you know
this is the funny thing right it's cause
there's no uniform rule
you know women will go out and they'll
say yeah i want people to notice me
that's why i dressed up and did all this
stuff i didn't do all this just for me i
put on to be appreciated women will
openly admit that do you have other
women who will be like
i didn't do this for you
the [ __ ] are you looking at so how do we
know
that yo you know what and though there's
a reason why that's the reason why
you're gonna get some gyms there's gonna
be like hey no tight clothes
no this no that because you're gonna see
people glancing no so so so
from now on
you go to the gym men and women full
joggings nobody's looking at all that
you know what uh hijab hobby but
that's the reason why they have hijab
let's go happy b you want to go to the
gym
full decked out stop don't talk about
proper hijab not hijab with the spandex
on the ass yeah and your songs
okay proper things yeah
and i don't even care live whatever life
that you want to live listen i just i
don't understand how people can exist in
society and and just have these insane
rules insane rules
[ __ ] don't stare at me then [ __ ] be
invisible what you want me to tell you
don't leave your house that's how you be
invisible all right there's a bunch of
[ __ ] otakus right now being like i
could teach you how to be invisible it's
not that difficult if you really want to
be it's it's possible
nah stop you're doing it come on bro
you're doing them
just like a whole ice because yeah
[ __ ] out of here bro slap your feet stop
your feet you're doing the most oh
you're doing the most i'm i'm done yeah
i got nothing else to say yeah man the
internet apparently flamed her i thought
that [ __ ] but of course they flamed her
i hope they flamed her the way she
reacted or she's like keep it pushing
keep
[ __ ] calm down
you're not dug down dude you're not one
hand on you're going flying okay don't
be tough you're not you're not the one
don't be tough you imagine a [ __ ]
tiny ass dude be like you're looking at
bro keep it pushing bro you know how
quickly that big ass day is going to put
you through the [ __ ] mirror hey
there's a tiny ass dude relax
do that challenge me to a boxing match
some of these [ __ ] are
delusional the way they talk to people
how how do you get off being that rude
yeah to somebody for no i could never
yeah
i could never think of talking to
somebody straight like just random like
down the street if you weren't about to
do something don't say nothing yeah keep
it pushing bro you keep it pushing did
you what you thugged out now pushing
and that's why you came back yo you got
enough yes you got a prong yo listen
these girls listen to asap rocky a few
times all of a sudden thinking they're
part of the asap crew shut the [ __ ] up
keep it pushed get out of here calm down
asap spandex